hello everyone I'm Richard and today
we're going to round off our look at the
more value orientated radians with a
look at two new RX 460s okay so AMD
envisaged the 460 as a small discrete
GPU offering a big performance uplift
over the 260x and 360 and requiring no
PCI Express power inputs whatsoever the
two models we've got well they're
actually premium end SKS with 4 gigs of
RAM Factory overclocks and yes power
sockets they're also pretty pricey too
costing $30 more than the $109 Target
price and the assus stricks and Sapphire
Nitro models we have here are actually
very similar in many ways the Polaris 11
GPU at the core of them is pretty power
efficient so the cooling assemblies we
have here are essentially Overkill but
it does mean you have a very very quiet
experience at least until you really
start pushing with overclocking that's
when those fans will kick in harder
display inputs are also so identical
it's a standard lineup of dual link DVI
display port and of course HDMI 2.0 so
yeah it's all rather different to the
reference design we've seen from AMD
which has a single fan no power input
and a much smaller layer overall the
cars we've got here are clearly designed
for gamers whereas the look of the AMD
original is perhaps geared more towards
those who want a small discrete card
capable of media sens of PC duties and
gaming too but we're more interested in
the gaming so let's take a look at it
credentials here beginning with
perennial favorite Crisis 3 okay then so
we're really pushing the card here using
the same presets at 1080p that we use
for more capable gpus but it's not
really the frame rate numbers here that
are so important compared to the
differentials between each card and yes
with both the Asus and the sapphire
models pushing to around 1250 MHz boost
performance is basically totally
identical in fact every measurement we
carried out on our Benchmark tests saw
them handing in frame rates within the
margin of error the highest differential
logged coming in at just 0.6 FPS and you
can see a healthy boost over the old
r7260 which basically performs a touch
faster than the r7360 now we log the new
card with an impressive 33% boost but
rx470 well that's way ahead why we've
included this In the comparison I'll
touch on in a moment okay so let's move
on to another title The Witcher 3 again
no holds B here we're running at the
same Ultra settings with Hair Works off
that we bench far more capable gpus at
but the results aren't bad at all we're
logging just 1460 here as the two we
have really are the same just a 0.1 FPS
differential between them now what we
have done here is to include the GTX 950
it's fair game actually as while the $19
rx460 is cheaper remember that we only
have the more expensive Factory
overclock versions to test the end
result is that the 950 is only 1 frame
per second slower but there's more this
is an assus low power GTX 950 without
the power input if we factor in an MSI
Factory overclock version perhaps more
equivalent to the RX 460s we have well
Nvidia actually moves ahead again rx470
is much much faster I'm talking 80%
faster here Hitman dx12 it's a game AMD
users love because it always scores so
well and here we see two things
happening first of all there's the
inbuilt radiant Advantage but we also
see the 4 gigs of ram in effect here
yeah there's no doubt here AMD is light
years ahead with a 44% performance
Advantage but again rx470
88% faster right then I think you
understand the LIE of the land here but
why do I keep including the rx470 in the
tests after all we're looking at $109
card stacked up against a product that
retails at
$180 it's not fair right well the bottom
line is this we we are testing premium
high-end 460s that actually cost
$140 spend around 30% more money on a
470 and you're getting over 80% more
performance so I can't help but feel
that where rx460 is really going to make
its Mark is with the base level cheap
cards but how do those 14 compute units
Stack Up compared to Prior radian
Generations which are likely to be
costing a whole lot less these days okay
so these benchmarks are are kind of
limited as AMD still hasn't fixed vsync
off support in dx12 for older radiant
Hardware meaning our fcap benchmarks
won't be accurate but we can see here in
the division on dx11 that there's a vast
performance golf with the 260 in the
region of 41% the 460 sits in between
the r7370 and
r9270x now these are based on the
classic AMD pit C design including the
likes of the 7850 and 7870 so yeah
Polaris 11 can be seen as a kind of
replacement for both of those cards with
much better power efficiency you will
note though that the r9280 the old
Tahiti chip it is a fair bit ahead and
the efficiencies in the new fourth gen
gcn can stack up quite a bit actually so
let's compare the same gpus in The
Witcher 3 now this may well be driver
related of course but the rx460 performs
great here 32% faster than 260x and 11%
faster than 270x amazingly it's even 5%
faster than the old 280 which has twice
as many compute units as the 460 now
even if we assume that the base model RX
460 isn't quite as fast to $109 that's
still a lot of GPU power for the money
the only issue is that the more
expensive 460s just don't seem so
appealing when rx470 is so well priced
and offers such exceptional performance
and yeah the RX 460 well it is power
efficient but perhaps not to the degree
that you might have been hoping for now
we have to bear in mind here that we're
dealing with Factory overclock models
with additional power delivery but the
bottom line is that a similarly
overclocked GTX 950 on 28 nanom only
consumes 10 watts more in our stress
test while not surprisingly the lower
power 950 sucks up just 169 wats again
I'd really like to see the stock 460
here for comparison it should be closer
to the lower power 950 for sure okay so
that's where we're at with the rx460 I
really hope if I can try out the 2 gig
model at some point because that's where
I think the value lies with this one
when we power up to the $140 price
bracket occupied by the Asus and the
sapphire we run into problems there's no
knockout blow against gtx950 either in
terms of performance or power efficiency
and also something else that needs
pointing out is that nvidia's driver
consumes Less in terms of CPU resources
meaning that GTX 950 May well be the
better bet when paired with with a
budget orientated CPU but perhaps more
importantly saving just a little more
money for your next GPU offers up a
colossal increase in performance I mean
in this respect the rx470 is genuinely
gamechanging it's essentially a
discounted rx480 with not much if
anything in terms of a loss in
performance do check out the benchmarks
on that Elsewhere on the channel and
also the video review we've got lined up
okay so this is where I'll check out if
you're considering a new GPU purchase
tell us about it in the comments below
like And subscribe to support our work
and I'll catch you next
time